the main clashes of the Russian army, as expected, do not occur with the regular units of the armed forces of ukraine, but with nationalist formations which, as you know, are directly responsible for the genocide in the donbass and the blood of civilians in the people's republics, in addition, the realistic elements introduced into the regular ukrainian units not only incite them to provide armed resistance, but in fact they play the role of detachments more according to the available information and this is confirmed by the results of objective control, we see that the Belgorod residents of her Nazis put up heavy weapons, including multiple rocket launchers right in the central regions of large cities, including Kyiv and Kharkov, they plan to call the return fire of Russian strike systems on an elderly quarter, in fact, they act in the same way as terrorists around the world hide behind people in the hope of then blaming Russia for civilian casualties, it is reliably known that in
All this is happening on the recommendation of foreign consultants, primarily American advisers, once again I appeal to the military personnel of the armed forces of Ukraine, do not allow the neo-Nazis of Bendera, he will use your children, your wives and the elderly as a human shield, take power into your own hands, it looks like it will be easier for us to agree than from this gang of drug addicts and neo-Nazis that settled in Kyiv and took hostage the entire Ukrainian people, I also want to give the highest assessment to the actions of Russian soldiers and officers, they act courageously, professionally, heroically, performing their military duty, successfully successfully solve the most important task of ensuring the security of our people and our fatherland